alors moi j'ai une peur qui city ou
poulet ne savais pas qui c'était dans
les marseillais sur le wt 2 on était
deux et il est un extrait je voulais
vous montrer dans les marseillais il n'y
a pas que des mauvais move ont par
exemple hier les candidats ont fait une
course d'obstacles en sumo et ça je me
suis dit ça y est voilà un gars assez là
c'est la vie regarder qu'à la matinée
heure on ne voit plus les maires
présents non plus les pis ça très nature
a tenu comme ça je suis mal car atténuer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les marseillais on va rappeler le
principe des marseillais tany
téléspectateurs et jesse et sa maman
sont venus nous rejoindre
alors là je vous demande et j'aimerais
tous les jeunes et toutes les mamans qui
sont là de regarder l'émission avec elle
parce que c'est important
ce qu'on va dire tout de suite et vous
allez nous dire pourquoi vous demain
google et pourquoi votre maman et et
triste vous appelez élise elisabeth
élise je peux vous appeler lise ya pâte
pour des raisons deux voies la salle où
les sens merci rappelez nous c'est quoi
les bars et les marseillais c'est la
marque phare de w9 qui existe depuis au
moins plus de cinq ans et l'idée très
simple on est une bande de potes dans un
endroit et on va suivre leurs aventures
là c'est une saison un peu particulière
où ils vont devoir faire des paris jouer
entre amis tout simplement et en suit
les aventures jour après jour alors
juste on en voit donc des marseillais
partout et ça donc vous êtes
marseillaise oui donc déjà ça c'est bon
très bien au départ voulu être
comédienne
c'est ça c'est ça alors nous étions en
couple avec avec un ryan benz et y aller
parce que c'était pas secret en voilà
tout et voilà de 15 à 17 ans moi aussi
j'étais avec à une meuf de 15 à 17 ans
voulait dire après vous avez commencé à
participer à des émissions de
téléréalité vous avez fait coup de jeune
à vega sur nrj12 et dans une interview
votre maman
elisabeth vous avez révélé qu'au départ
il n'était pas question pour votre fille
de participer à l'émission est là
donc refusé et au ce soir vous avez un
coup de gueule contre l'émission c'est
quoi quel est votre problème avec
l'émission pourquoi elisabeth vous êtes
énervé contre ces démissions parce qu'on
en parle beaucoup ici et on dit souvent
que c'est vrai que pour les jeunes après
c'est compliqué de faire de vivre une
vie normale
et vous vous avez dit que tu ici avec
complètement sombré sombrer complètement
c'est à dire la première émission débat
essayé c'était super ouais elle est
sorti de là dedans c'est super la
dernière là elle a fait n'importe quoi
je ne vais pas reconnue elle a été
influencé la fièvre et mal oui vous avez
des qui devrait même prêté votre votre
fille de bien et c'est un gars qui
m'avait même téléphone
j'ai téléphoné à la prod aussi je vous
avais dit que c'était une garde parce
que le faisais n'importe quoi elle
sortait avec pierre paul jacques elle se
montrer nue que jessica jamais en fait
c'est le hasard j il sortait quand
j'étais moi en tournage voilà les
réseaux sociaux je voyais que tout ce
qui se passe est déjà dans les épisodes
alors en plus vous l'avez reprocher
parce que vous êtes rapproché d'anthony
d'antony dans les marseillais versus les
réserves mais après vous étiez avec
kevin oui et après vous êtes nés après
vous être vous être rapprochés pour
andré antoni jaloux ça c'est une
histoire mais rocambolesque quoi année
totalement moi je ne suis pas du tout
reconnu et vous êtes sorti
combien de garçons dont les marseillais
ben j'ai commencé en novembre 2016 et 3
roadmap elle adore mes trois arrêts 3 et
donc et vous ça vous plaisait pas à pas
dit mais qu'est ce que vous reprochez à
la prod vous reprocher la prod quoi
parce que c'est elle qui a envie d'aller
la preuve daniel a rien à voir là dedans
la pauvre la prod s'il ya des gens qui
s'inscrivent si elle était prise au
casting si vous voulez qu'il fasse
c'est qu'elle joue non mais quelque part
c'est eu quand même que de temps en
temps ils doivent leur dire avec et non
mais c'est sait comment ça se passe dans
l'entourage parce que moi en soit j'ai
été dedans donc mais c'est à dire qu'en
fait on arrive moi je t'avais valentin
donc mon couple actuel au jour
d'aujourd'hui
et voilà on est influencé on s'est privé
la téléralité comment ça se passe on
sait qu'il faut des clash foot histoire
d'amour des ruptures sinon belle
personne que tu vas aller aujourd'hui
sortir avec celui de la confiance
moi j'étais naïve et semeraro ma famille
non plus un couteau sous la gorge
adamant ça veut dire quoi ou alors ça
veut dire parce que non julien a raison
de dire ça mine de rien et on vous dit
on vous dit quoi il faut absolument
sortir akbar naseri bien que ce serait
bien pour l'histoire m'a clairement
c'est quoi influencer ses influences et
ses du film on est venu voir dès que
charlie et donc on a fait à ce prix de
moines envoyés dans l'émission la
première sentiment copain et je suis à
peine arrivé
on n'a pas téléphone rien et moi on m'a
influencé dans le sens on nous disait
c'est pas un mec pour toi valentin takka
takka la production oui tu n'arrives ses
24 ans mais moi je reconnais que j'ai
été extrêmement naïve et pas pardon
alors juste me faire l'avocat du diable
par dont vous avez fait trois télé
réalité il semble vraiment donc vous
vous seriez la première commande du
fonctionnaire a dû aller bien géante ny
de la première non mais dans la première
dans la première primaire j'étais
nouvelle mais il ya quand même des
images graphiques et des danseurs dans
les autres parce que je suis un store on
n'avait pas besoin de l'influencé de
nouvelles il a loué à lady les mamans
des marseillais en à miami oui les
parents se retrouver dans un instant
parce qu'on aura d'y être de koh lanta
aussi qu'il va venir nous voir et
l'aigle art lui il est hyper v ner
contre koh lanta monde va finir avec
vous également elise et jesse puisque
vous avez des choses à dire et vous avez
vous dire exactement quelles sont les
pressions que vous avez subie et mathieu
à son avis la dessus je crois qu'il a
les révélations de fer a tout de suite
sur ce week-end alors jesse vous avez
fait les marseillais votre maman elle
n'était pas contente parce que on va
faire un petit résumé de ce coffret dans
les bars y est c'est vrai qu'on vous
voit souvent d'élus des salaires malgré
vous n'aimez pas les vous n'aimez pas à
m'imposer a pas aimé les vêtements quoi
on vous a dit c'est la chaleur peut
parler oui donc voilà j'ai fait parler
et ben on sait comment j'arrive on me
dit j'ai un job chez un truc nu pieds
nus nas site atteindra quoi mais
j'arrive dans les mares segaunes reste
du monde
ouais et on me dit donc l'ati a job tu
dois faire gagner ta famille cha le job
de shooting photos nues on n'est pas une
fille dans ma famille mais ça a toujours
été moelleux nunu ça a toujours été
comme ça j'ai rien compris
si kate résume alors contre le reste du
monde aussi
la ville a déjà eu en fait oui série de
la wilaya des jeux il a recommencé ses
les marseillais contre le reste du monde
on sait contre d'autres tels de
personnalités télé réalité produit
demandent au détenu
c'est vrai que la production lui a
demandé d'être tenu maintenant parce que
c'est pour gagner mais bon voilà déjà je
vois pas pourquoi on a demandé de nous
les gens non mais on lui a demandé de
dire 'nous voyons
non mes bras
lui nu on était dans une baignoire
jusqu'au bout si j'étais alors je
n'étais pas obligé encore une fois on
n'a jamais mis un couteau sous la gorge
dans tous les actes que j'ai pu faire
c'est ça mais totalement mais en plus
affûté pour une séquence qu'on faisait
une séquence nudisme
non c'était juste une photo nue dans un
bain avec de la mousse parlement n'était
pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je regarde pas possible l'espagne où je
peux pas je passe moi-même je suis
d'état brisé c'est pas possible
excuse-moi higuain de baston
[Musique]
ça nous
m
alors avait il ya plein de top model
d'actrice et rire leur métier pause ou
alors fonds simule de faire l'amour avec
moi moi même j'ai fait deux heures dans
des films avec marion cotillard
notamment alors alors mais de là à moi
tu fais ça sans moi nunu nuit pendant
alors oui j'aurais plus durement et
encore une fois je regrette ce que j'ai
pu faire c'est des erreurs je pense que
tous les gens qui s'y fait des erreurs
notamment bien sûr mais moi j'en fais
tous les voilà j'ai clairement jeté dans
le cercle vicieux où je me disais il
faut que je fasse même séquence pour
être visible à l'écran mais maintenant
elles reculent que j ai marre de moi on
attend de moi
vous vous avez mille de trois émissions
à vous rendre compte de saison la
première comme l'a demandé j'ai jamais
influença parce que je vous apprends à
connaître on verra mais du coup je
faisais des histoires en étant moi même
c'est comme ça lorsque moi j'aimerais
j'aimerais en résumé quel est votre coup
de gueule parce que en fait maman
elizabeth
vous aimeriez parce que maintenant je
crois que votre fille était en
dépression c'est à 10 mois elle est
rentrée elle était en dépression ont
heureusement qu'elle a vu sa famille et
pour la remonter parce que je crois
jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui peut-être à
elle irait voir les psys et c'est parce
qu'on a été quand même insulté
énormément y a pas de mal à les voir des
petits riens mais bien sûr on a été très
insulté sur les réseaux sociaux on
venait me même me traiter de mois de
garde de vous sent très ému et si c'est
vrai qu'est ce cas parce qu'on fait
parce qu'elle s'aperçoit qu'elle est un
mauvais souvenir et un goût les
marseillais maintenant oui vraiment où
vous le referiez pas voilà si c'était à
refaire
non c'est vrai la première émission
enfin tu vois j'ai fait des choses
aujourd'hui je manie ici parce que j'ai
fait les martiens donc encore une fois
j'ai pas dire lui dépassé par spéciale
non j'ai pas dire que je regrette
d'avoir fait tout ça parce que ça
pourrait peut-être ouvrir des portes sur
d'autres choses pas sur la télé réalité
mais aujourd'hui moi ce que j'ai fait a
engendré à mes parents aimaient mon
copain qui s'y voient encore ça ben
ouais bon alors vous des gens la
mascotte vous avez vous aviez un copain
avant d'y aller mais je vais rencontrer
dans les marseillais dans les primaires
c'est après il a vu que vous étiez
sûreté que d'autres mais voilà bon il
est venu je les quitte ea à l'écran
c'est il y en a pris un coup sur sa
fierté et je regrette aujourd'hui encore
le mal que j'ai pu faire
mais ce qui me touche vraiment comment
les parents ils ont toujours été là pour
moi
et de savoir que ma mère a été insulté
tous là est ce qu'il faudrait une
question précise elle est très vite très
vite mais ça n ya aucun jugement juste
pour dire effectivement c'est vrai que
j'ai vu dans les émissions qu'on
demandait souvent je citerai pas
lesquels est ce que tu peux te mettre en
couple avec untel ou untel
si un couple ça marchera mieux manon le
remède se mettre en couple on en a 200
brasse et un petit peu il y avait la
couette on était née la lumière mais il
faisait rien en vrai ma question est la
suivante on a demandé de te mettre là
dans les marseillais avec canto tu
ressens rien pour lui c'est la prod qui
donne monnaie on est d'accord
oui voilà sauf que tout à l'heure tu
m'as dit rien en même temps bah oui j'ai
vraiment couché avec lui là bas donc sa
personne tellement il à craindre ni rien
en abattant les montants étaient
totalement perdus dans cette émission
c'est à dire qu hongbin moi je voudrais
aller en bois qui avait perdu on buvait
ses paroles
tous les lundis soirs les amène donc un
soutien non plus aller je vous dis pas
encore une fois que ce que j'ai fait
n'est ni journée tout sur le tweed à
quoi vous savez que la marque et je
reconnais j'ai 24 ans après j'ai ouais
non mais après dans une région troublée
c'est facile effectivement je comprends
vous plaisir elle a 24 ans elle aurait
pu dire non c'est pas aussi simple que
ça
je vous assure quand vous avez la télé
tout ça vous est pris dans un espèce
on peut bien sûr dire non mais regardez
tous les reportages où on voit les gens
les confessions les machins faire les
guignols on se dit aussi habile à l'air
con mais parce qu'aussi aller le caveau
rôle vous allez bien faire un petit truc
à moi de chiens pour croyez messi messi
donné lui à puis après ils fêtent
l'anniversaire de son chien on veut mais
moi ça que je suis là mais n'avait que
ça je lui donne pas raison mais si on
met les chérubins style que je regardais
et je défends personne mais mine de rien
alors la production il faut aussi leur
métier ils font de la télé
forcément et les règles elles sont elles
sont claires avant donc c'est ça le truc
c'est que c'est vrai qu'après vous vous
n'avez pas supporté et moi je peux
comprendre tout à fait et je vous vous
jette pas la pierre
c'est juste que votre message c'est
peut-être aux jeunes l'ont qui nous
regardent et précision mais qui se dit
en mai et qui sont des jeunes gens qui
nous regardent et qui existe mon but
dans la vie c'est juste d'être connu moi
j'ai rencontré plein de jeunes cet été
qui m'ont dit le 14 ou 15 ans moi ce que
je voudrais faire plus tard c'est faire
marseillais à me faire faire si vous
faire c'est ce que parce qu'elle est en
train de vous dire c'est que mine de
rien vous pensez peut-être deux semaines
ou deux mois où je suis pas à vous
éclater et eux mêmes pas en plus et
qu'après ça va vous suivre toute votre
vie qu'après peut-être pour retrouver un
cursus normal et pour parce que de ceux
qui iront ceux qui restent il y en a pas
beaucoup moins parce qu'une fois que
vous ne pouvez plus vous mettre tout nu
où vous avez plus qu au repos
tout nu que si vous allez faire donc
voila depuis la saison la plus haute
donc forcément vous dit pas c'est pas la
production qui fait mal son embarras
c'est juste que ce sont des émissions je
pense qu'il faut éviter de faire pour
les jeunes parce que c'est pas un métier
alors on peut les faire bien sûr mais en
sachant que c'est juste son s'amuser et
qu'après on passe à autre chose et on
fera un usage qu'on ait l'honnêteté de
filmer dans ces cas là les soirées où on
leur donne de l'alcool voilà pour les
gens pourraient baisser un peu parce que
c'est qu'on peut pas conduire mes sens à
tout ça on peut pas rester sur wii très
vite gilbert d'elisabeth j'ai une
question pour vous pourquoi n'êtes vous
pas intervenue avant mais il avait l'air
très proche de votre fille il fallait
dire stop bien avant qu'elle était de
taille et reviennent à bas le premier
marseillais n'a pas été le cas bon là je
lui ai dit avant de partir tu devrais
pas faire cette émission m'a dit maman
je resterai moi même et je ferai pas de
bêtises et l anafé malheureuse mal et
influençable non mais alors maxime b je
sais juste une question est-ce que à
présent après cette affaire
vous allez arrêter la télé réalité soit
on rentre dans une interview vous avez
dit elise que vous auriez des plans pour
les anges
voilà elle est inquiète pas compris
ensemble alors vous allez faire les ans
la mer quelque part oui des pleins oui
les plans est ce que vous allez faire
les anges ou est ce que vous allez faire
d'autres téléralité and on à moi pour le
moment concrètement à la télé c'est
voilà c'est pas la vraie vie et c'est un
cercle vicieux est aujourd'hui la télé
c'est à court terme moi j'ai envie de
avoir des portes qui s'ouvrent sur la
comédie sera dans le sait que ça
difficile parce que j'ai appris une
étiquette de fils de télé réalité et la
france malheureusement on a une
mentalité un peu comme ça mais voilà moi
j'ai envie de reprendre mes passions
pour regretter comment vous regrettez
d'avoir fait cette émission je regrette
d'avoir fait la dernière je vais pas
dire que je regrette d'avoir fait les
autres parce qu'aujourd'hui j'en suis là
pour répondre à ça oui mais oui mais
est-ce que vous regardez pas ce que vous
n'auriez peut-être même pas été connus
vous auriez vécu tranquillement votre
maman se serait pas fait insulter sur
les réseaux sociaux ou dans la rue et
peut-être vous auriez fait autre chose
un métier artistique
ouais totalement mais aujourd'hui je
regrette pas réellement je regrette
juste de la manière que j'ai fait que je
me suis perdue a demandé alors je vais
vous dire sachez que les gens oublient
très vite ou deux dans un an ou deux ans
toulouse roblique vous avez fait les
marchés ce qu'il soit vous le dis
franchement c'est le temps les images
rares
c'est que megan ça marchera pour vous
mais c'est juste moi j'en voulais vous
montrer à 100 parce que tous les jeunes
qui nous regardent et qui je veux être
connu sachez que c'est pas vraiment il
avait quand vous être prêt et qu'après
il est venu me dire j'aimerais faire ça
moi aussi
bah oui mais voilà et télécoms 13 ans
oui et non moi on m'a proposé de
regarder cette émission c'était la
première et la dernière fois que je la
regardais oui j'ai trouvé une hypocrisie
extraordinaire dans cette émission on
beat chaque fois que le mot qu'on ait
prononcé alors qu'à côté de ça on voit
un certain nombre d'imagés etc
je trouve ces émissions d'une hypocrisie
totale et là où je ne suis pas d'accord
avec vous cyril c'est que je ne pense
pas que les règles soient claires au
départ s'il est candidat avec des seins
mais de façon claire peut-être dans les
autres épisodes est en tout cas jesse et
merci tu as vécu
[Applaudissements]